Bella a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono Favij oggi siamo su
Hogwarts Legacy ve l'avevo detto ragazzi
che non avrei portato Ve l'ho già
portato in anteprima un paio di
settimane fa Tra poco uscirà Comunque
adesso ce l'ho ancora in anteprima però
posso portarvelo per quanto io non porti
più Gameplay ci sono comunque delle
eccezioni che io faccio pur non andando
più tanti Gameplay perché vabbè so che
questi video andranno meno del solito ma
fa niente perché Hogwarts Legacy parla
del mondo di Harry Potter come sapete
tutti se mi conoscete bene Io amo il
mondo di Harry Potter da quando sono
bambino ho fatto parte della mia tutto
tutte le cose che c'avete già inutile mi
ripeto Siamo lieti di informarla che lei
ha diritto a frequentare il quinto anno
alla scuola di magia Stregoneria di
Hogwarts la lettera che nella mia vita
non mi è mai arrivato l'anno scolastico
inizia il primo settembre l'unica scuola
al mondo dove non vedi l'ora che inizino
le lezioni non la mia vecchia scuola
quella non volevo iniziarsene comunque
una cosa che non mi torna ehm Weasley
è la professoressa Weasley c'è una
professoressa quindi che si chiama io
non so bene la Lor di Harry Potter sono
sono un fa un fake fan quindi non so
bene come mai ci sia la professoressa
Weasley questa cosa non mi torna però
vabbè allora per quanto riguarda invece
il mio personaggio Ecco quello ci metto
un attimo di tempo Scusatemi Secondo me
Dai È simile Peccato per il naso perché
non ci somiglia molto il naso Secondo me
però a parte quello ci stiamo Vabbè dai
Let's go raga Allora io questa parte
l'ho già giocata però la rigiochiamo
tanto è tutto Gameplay Grazie il suo
aiuto prima dell'inizio dell'anno è
stato
Per fortuna la mia descrizione criptica
non ti ha scoraggiato dal cercarci mi
sono materializzato in destinazioni più
vaghe di questa quando è arrivato il tuo
gufo ha pensato meglio non parlarne qui
Elias
discutiamone durante il viaggio però
Hogwarts Ci attendono un banchetto e una
cerimonia di smistamento Ottima idea A
meno che al tuo nuovo Pupillo non
dispiaccia la mia presenza Niente
affatto signore dopo di te
non torno al castello da secoli credo
che sarà bello rivedere quell'ammasso di
rocce
[Musica]
qua non ho capito cosa ha visto raga
Cioè ha visto qualcosa ma non ho capito
cosa proprio
Madonna cioè se io penso che l'ultima
Harry Potter che ho giocato quando ero
piccolo era quello
[Musica]
Eccolo qua la Playstation uno che era
Vabbè
ridicola in confronto a livello di
grafica Questa è una roba che non esiste
mi sembrai Boh Prova a dare al me
bambino questo gioco e probabilmente non
avrei avuto altro all'infuori di questo
l'altro questo non è come prendere il
pullman di casa mia quando andavo a
scuola non era così però va bene
E chi sarebbe il tuo compagno di viaggio
Ciao mi chiamo Paolo
a scuola Sì no
Peccato per strada
straordinario indubbiamente nessun
docente ha mai sentito di una missione a
Hogwarts così tarda e nemmeno io infatti
Siccome gli studenti del quinto anno
affinano le loro abilità da anni il
preside mi ha chiesto di mettere in pari
questo nuovo arrivo prima del trimestre
Beh non potevi avere un mentore migliore
hai letto questo
Sì l'ho letto non tutti concordano sulla
pericolosità di Run rock
devo ancora convincere i miei colleghi
al Ministero ma sono convinto che si
tratti di una minaccia molto grave ed è
stata tua moglie
eliasr che mi ha avvisato su di lui mesi
fa Miriam ma come
mi ha scritto di RAM Rock prima di
morire
si chiedeva se il Ministero sapesse
delle sue attività
prima di poter rispondere
ho ricevuto questo poi non mi ha più
inviato nient'altro eliosar l'ha portato
il suo gufo ma senza una lettera posso
solo presumere in fretta
per proteggerlo probabilmente
non posso aprirlo è protetto da un
incantesimo davvero molto potente sembra
metallo Goblin quel simbolo cos'è quel
bagliore
non lo vedo
per la barba di Merlino Ma come hai
aspetta
to
Beh è una roba che capita spesso anche
quando prendi l'autobus Allora con le
schiattato così
Il Cocchiere che sta portando avanti la
carrozza tutto a posto
normale giornata di lavoro
Ah Loro sono comparsi perché abbiamo
visto qualcuno morire credo perché
quelli li vedi solo se vedi qualcuno
schiattare sono comparsi in questo
momento per questo perché è morto
l'altro credo eh Però potrebbe
se è stato fatto benissimo
[Musica]
qua ci sarebbe un arresto momento
ma anche così va bene
e da Game of Thrones è tutto
mi chiamo succede quando si becca la
freccia no
sei ferito solo un poco
tieni ti rimetterai subito è una pozione
rigeneratrice perché è sta roba il succo
di caccole
premo il tasto giù per cura cos'è Ma che
schifo
ed er moment
non ci credo che
diavolo gli ha preso a quell'affare
attaccare una carrozza in volo e ho idea
Ah posso già muovermi da quella che hai
trovato è una passaporta passaporta un
oggetto magico che porta chi lo tocca in
un posto specifico
Cercherò di non fare spoiler Non so se
fare riferimenti a Harry Potter raga che
magari qualcuno non l'ha visto Vabbè ma
se Guardate sto Gameplay l'avete visto
per forza
lo farò ma restami accanto non sappiamo
chi ha creato la passaporta
o perché
ok Non ho ben capito chi sia
l'antagonista di Hogwarts Legacy
ovviamente quasi parla di Cioè in Harry
Potter si parla di Voldemort l'altra
animali fantastici si parla di
Grindelwald qua c'è questo Run Rock che
non ho ben capito chi sia
Però vabbè Madonna
affacciazzerò Ragazzi dove ci ho portato
una cassaforte se mi assicuri di
sentirti bene e non ti dispiace
assecondarmi vorrei dare un'occhiata in
certo signore vamos gli avrei risposto
vamos però va bene Lorenzo rispondi Come
vuoi
mi fa morire che il protagonista parla
tutto il tempo Cioè nel senso In genere
Non parlano mai quelli i protagonisti
dei videogiochi personalizzati non
parlano cioè raro cioè leggere Lorenzo
Ostuni sentire che parla fa strano Vabbè
ma sapete che ho giocato quando ho
giocato l'anteprima non mi da quando
l'ho giocata Non mi ricordo più i tasti
Cioè dovrei iniziare veramente tutto a
zero Non mi ricordo nulla nulla
mi ricordo come si lanciano le magie
Vamos
Ma a cosa serve ai maghi bloccare la
strada se sanno che basta un altro
incantesimo per togliere il blocco
cioè cosa ha servito al tizio che la
blocca cosa serve Tanto lo sanno che
sta questo l'ho distrutto
bellissimo Ah non mi aveva sbloccato il
coso per sparare le magie Ecco perché
Adesso lui mi evidenzia le cose che
posso colpire
Ok Questa cosa è assurdo Comunque è
pazzesco raga Cioè sta roba incredibile
piccioni
Peccato che non trovi tipo i galeoni
dentro le cose che rompi Boh
Madonna raga che è bellissimo
Ma lo zio Dov'è Eccolo scusi però stia
attento che cacchio sto facendo tutto io
farà apparire qui in quella pietra
cristallizzata
dove siamo non c'è Gol
ci ha portati dentro la gringot sta roba
qua c'è tutto sotto sto bordello tutto
sto bordello per entrare alla gringot
potrei entrare da diagonal Alley entri
la diagonale e fai prima
[Musica]
Questo sta qua da millenni aspettare che
arrivasse qualcuno
un attimo eh che sono comunque le attese
che fa in banca le poste uguali
Benvenuti alla gringot la banca dei
maghi grazie
Siamo entrati dall'altra parte
precisamente
la chiave
la chiave di sua moglie Oh sì Ma certo
[Musica]
da questa è la gringot non ci metterei
niente ogni volta che andiamo alla Green
got anche in Harry Potter cose succede
sempre qualcosa quindi l'unico posto
dove non mettere le cose la cringo che
svaligiano le cose Ogni volta no Ma chi
è che ha rubato questo è impossibile non
si può rubare la gringot tutti che
rubano tutti tutti tutti gli ungue Harry
Potter da camera blindata tutti pietra
filosofale sparita Qua stiamo entrando
non mettete la roba la gringot Ma voi
costate la Gringo vado Allora ragazzi
questa cosa qua è incredibile ci sarà
cascata che lava via l'incantesimo
bella come Blu Tornado di Gardaland Ecco
la cascata
Eccoci qua
Sono bellissime le colonne sonore che
riportano Harry Potter cioè fanno le
prime note e poi cambia l'ultima volta
che sono entrati qui sono ormai secoli
che un Goblin fa la guardia ci ha
percepito lo stipendio a cazzo senza
fare niente
raggiunto la visitata fino a oggi
Madonna è bellissima guardare in giro
che palle
[Applauso]
bastava mettere una password Invece tipo
una passo verifica in due passaggi dal
posto No Gringo
posso guardare Vabbè Entriamo va
Eh non si sa mai
siamo in una camera blindata cosa
dovremmo cercare se poi le candele sono
accese non si squagliano mai
della chiave della camera blindata 12
una due chiudere la finestra
professoresse
Fammi riflettere deve esserci qualcosa
per
[Musica]
forse
Revello Sì un incantesimo di Rivelazione
o ora o mai più vediamo cosa ci sfugge
Allora devo fare io Ah figo ma io
comunque non ho capito perché la gringot
debbano chiudere le persone dentro non
sono colpevoli di omicidio non lo so
ripeti
lo ho visto qualcosa
avvicinati un po' e Riprova Allora
leverio Ah ecco qua devo fare
Ma tu quando prendi una stanza alla
Pringles puoi fare quel cazzo che vuoi
questa non è una normale camera blindata
temo che l'uscita dovremo sudarci In che
senso
bello
che cacchio è ormai Ormai ho capito cosa
devo fare nelle cose Adesso riflesso sul
pavimento Ma la posizione delle statue
non corrisponde devo bloccarlo quando lo
fa quando ha cambiato posizione il
riflesso si è girato verso la luce e
muoviti muoviti Forse dovresti lanciare
Ma va No veramente Grazie professore Lei
sì che è molto arguto va bene
adesso ci fa un culo quadro in Dark
siamo in Dark Souls ragazzi Eccoci qua
ragazzi
Dark Souls
Siamo nella merda professore
incantesimi e combatto Anch'io faccio
anch'io Accio Ma se uno per caso dice
Accio Capatonda arrivati tipo uno senza
capelli cosa fare devo picchiare
Ahia porco del demonio ma ti devo fare
il sacrificio prego bellissimo
Dai questa cosa è bellissima non ha
senso quindi schiacciare solo triangolo
per pararsila senza fare il sacrificio
Beh non ha senso fare un cazzo a quanto
pare aiuto che male Eh vabbè Mi sa che
tu hai un tempo limite per il protego
poi non non ti funziona più
dai Bravo sei pronto
Come lui
ha fatto lumus
Ok
dai Ciao sono andato scavata non ho più
Cure ragazzi quindi attenzione lumus
raga dov'è che ne so se vuole quelle
cose qua Ok va bene Ah figo
e il simbolo che c'era sulla chiave Mo
dice la stessa cosa guarda eh
come cazzo siamo a mordor
bellissimo sto male Cos'è sta roba è un
horcrux ho sparatoria incredibile ma non
penso
[Musica]
bomboniera
prof tutto bene
come hai fatto
ma che posto è questo non lo so ma ho
trovato questa cosa sopra quella
bacinella
non è una bacinella
è un pensatore per vedere i ricordi con
lacci dentro
sicuramente il pensatore erano le storie
di Instagram nel mondo di Harry Potter e
vedi le cose dello
fa come me
acidi Non ficcare la faccia dentro non
ho capito sta roba si sono avvicinati
Chi minchia è questo
[Musica]
è tutto pronto hai nascosta bene Sei
troppo
mi chiedo se il percorso che abbiamo
creato sia impossibile da seguire a chi
affronta questo cammino affidiamo dei
segreti potentissimi e conoscenze che
altri faranno di tutto per avere sì e se
abbiamo ragione Charles la strega o il
mago che supererà le prove meriterà di
ottenere quella conoscenza e quindi la
responsabilità che ne deriva
abbiamo fatto il possibile
[Musica]
è questo che vedi
il bagliore che le circondava Sì signore
stupefacente posso vedere la magia
tracce di magia Antica per la precisione
[Musica]
Miriam ha sempre saputo che questa magia
era reale
ma non ha potuto
[Musica]
Miriam e forse anche George sono morti
mentre cercavano un sapere assopito da
secoli
e pare che sia tu la chiave per capirne
il motivo
sono molto diverso rispetto a com'era un
attimo fa arriva qualcuno
chi erano Non lo so Vabbè signore lei
non dovrebbe trovarsi qui eh
[Musica]
proprio come pensare questo qua
sembra proprio che la mia reputazione mi
preceda pensavo che nessuno sarebbe
venuto alla camera blindata di rakam E
tu perché sei qui
questo non ti riguarda basta che mi
consegnate quello che avete trovato dopo
e metteremo una pietra
quindi siamo noi che signore
e loro avevano la chiave
il Signore devo proprio insistere posso
fare entrare solamente chi è in possesso
della chiave e lei
pensavo che poteva fare peggio
ora
dove eravamo io non ti darò niente
bene
allora forse il tuo giovane amico sarà
più collaborativo
Oh merda
Ah ma non lo dobbiamo affrontare noi
questo perché forse
a Facci lucazzi Comunque no attenta che
scappiamo noi no
si è riaperta la porta dietro
Ciao Come uscire
prof occhio Porco demonio
fai inventarmi un Leviosa sul con la
colonna che cade
proprio la magia signor Ostuni lei non è
in grado Eh
vabbè
celato anche bene
qua rischiavamo grossissimo
Va bene bella prof
il medaglione e il modo per raggiungerli
voleva che qualcuno con la tua abilità
arrivasse qui
Vieni alla cerimonia di smistamento
Ok C'è tutto sto casino e poi siamo
arrivati a Hogwarts della cerimonia di
smistamento
Ma cosa Minchia cioè proprio giusto un
attimo prima fatto quasi siamo morti ma
fa niente
bellissimo Dimmi che compare il titolo
Awards Legacy Ti prego non c'è bisogno
vieni qua no Guarda che roba
Ti prego ti prego
ti prego mettimelo
[Musica]
Complimenti Complimenti
amoci a sto punto no
così è finisce bello bello bello ragazzi
Veramente no fatto veramente molto bene
molto bene
non sono sorpresissimo perché avevo già
giocato per perché mi sono sempre preso
la prima volta quindi l'ho presa più
siamo già in ritardo ma poi smistamento
dove che sono le finto anno io
come fai a smistare nel quinto anno non
sono un esperto ma così mi sembra più
appropriato Ora devo studiare Questo
medaglione ma prima contatterò il
Ministero
Riferirò di George e avviserò diranno
per adesso quello che è successo stasera
deve rimanere Fra me tranquillo
a scuola
[Musica]
al cappello parlante è sempre quello c'è
solo un cappello parlante fine
Black
come Black
Preparati a incontrare fa parte della
casata dei Black
madonna Che palle sto tipo Ma chi l'ha
buttato lì a fare il preside
Ah forse non mi nota nessuno Non è vero
mi sta guardando tutti magari vado a
farlo smistamento nessuno mi paga meglio
c'è una persona
Quindi c'è un black c'è una Weasley
va bene
la prof da dietro Chi è chiedo per un
amico però a destra
talento da vendere vedo
Ma dove mi collochi Ah sì sei un po' più
grande degli altri vero grazie Quello lo
vede Basta che c'hai gli occhi che non
hai
[Musica]
concerti aspettative per così dire
quindi non decido io decide lui sto male
sto male raga
Dovevo iniziare a esplorare 100%
la faccio seria eh Raga non so cosa mi
esce fuori non si può scoprire con uno
spirito avventurato
anche i professori Hanno diverse cose da
insegnarti chissà
avverto qualcosa in te
un senso di
noi e la pasta che ho mangiato prima
piccante un po'
audacia curiosità l'alta ambizione la
mia è
Io penso di avere tutte e quattro quindi
che schiaccio curiosità audacia lealtà
ambizione
[Musica]
ma vi direi
No curiosità penso più curiosità tra
questi anche lealtà Però vabbè credo di
avere una mente elastica
Sei molto intelligente solo perché te
l'ho detto io perché non lo stai dicendo
può lasciare gli altri perplessi e hai
una mente scattante impari in fretta
figo Mi sta un po' descrivendolo a
partire a corpo nero davvero
[Musica]
Ah mi ha messo a corvonero
Ah mi ha buttato su corvonero proprio
quindi io devo accettare io sono io ho
fatto il test su Botter ma esco sempre
Grifondoro però vabbè è un tassorosso
una volta mi è uscito Sapete che vi dico
Va benissimo cioè no Aspetta fammi
pensare
corvo nero ma va bene cioè nel senso non
va benissimo
Grazie ragazzi
sono un corvonero mai uscito su
Pottermore mai l'avrò fatto 60 volte mi
è uscito 59 volte Grifondoro e una tasto
rosso qua mi è uscito corvo nero Ma
quando mai vabbè sti cazzi Va bene va
bene ci può stare
[Musica]
qualcuno inizi dal quinto anno sarà una
bella sfida ma sono certa che sarai
all'altezza Sì professoressa questo è
l'ingresso alla sala comune di corvonero
per entrare dovrei risolvere un enigma
Minchia ma tutte le volte una una volta
Chi ha vissuto di più fantasma o
Poltergeist
io che cazzo ne so scusi ma non ho
capito
non essere non è mai stato vivo
Bravo Meno male che c'è lui perché ci
fosse stato per me
ben fatto ora Entra e vai a dormire
Domani sarà un gran giorno tornerò
a dormire fuori cioè come funziona c'è
un letto per chi non risolve gli
enigmista qua
Grazie prof Arrivederci Grazie gentile
Questa è la mcgranitt di Hogwarts Legacy
Va bene Più roba stranissima con questa
roba nel senso non risolve L'enigma non
dormi
bello bello voglio andare alla torre di
astronomia la prima cosa che voglio fare
posso girarmi e fare le cose
carina
ma bellissima guarda che Ma è bellissima
cioè io ma i dormitori ragazzi sono
pieni di
letti e robe Poi ce ne sono quattro
letteralmente nessuno
Cioè mi faccio gli stracazzi miei io la
suite di hogwart zio bellissimo ragazzi
Questo era il primo episodio Hogwarts
Legacy io lo concludo qua e ne uscirà
più o meno uno al giorno per il primo
periodo perché almeno così vedete come
va avanti la storia io lo voglio giocare
un sacco in questi giorni quindi per
forza del voglio fare questa cosa qua
perché mi sono stracasato e come vedete
il gameplay molto diverso dal solito
perché ehm ci sono molti meno tagli meno
zoom non è roba alla Favij ma è più al
vi faccio vedere il gioco vi faccio
vedere di questo Gameplay incredibile
Perché a me piace tantissimo questo
Legacy Spero vi piaccia so che non sono
video che vanno perché purtroppo i
Gameplay ormai non vanno più ma è una
roba che a me piace fare Quindi ve la
sto portando lo stesso perché perché mi
piace quindi niente eh ci vediamo
Appunto domani con un altro episodio
della corsa Legacy iscrivetevi al canale
lasciate un commento mi piace e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video se
trovo il telecomando che sta qua bene
ragazzi